well what a mess and this is not just a
soap opera at the top of the Tory party
it's doing huge damage to our economy
and to the reputation of our country and
the public are paying with higher prices
with higher mortgages so we can't have a
revolving door of chaos we can't have
another experiment at the top of the
Tory party that is an alternative and
that's a stable labor government and the
public are entitled to have their say
and that's why there should be a general
election
some simple people is trust her time in
office pretty humiliating the damage
that has been inflicted on the public
through higher prices and mortgages is
considerable this is not a soap opera
these are real lives that are being
impacted by the mess at the top of the
Tory party we've had this revolving door
we've had these experiments at the top
of the Tory party the public are
entitled to choose between this utter
chaos and a labor party which will
stabilize the economy and have got a
clear plan for growth for living
standards and for jobs of the future we
need a general election so the public
can make their mind up about this utter
chaos isn't there an argument that a
general election might actually prolong
the instability to an outcome of that
general election did we need more
instability now or just a chance for a
clean State and just to stabilize the
ship the risk at the moment is
continuing with this chaos not having a
stable labor government so that's why
there should be a general election we
can't just allow the Tory party to keep
putting up the next candidate in the
middle of this chaos there is a choice
there's a labor party that's capable of
you know stabilizing the economy has a
clear plan and the public entitled to
choose between that stable labor
government and this utter chaos of the
conservatives are you ready for
government this is not the context you
would have wanted to take over we are
ready to form a government to stabilize
the economy and Implement a real plan
for growth for living standards to help
people through a cost of living crisis
and that's the choice now a stable labor
government or this utter chaos from the
conservatives